こんにちははじめ社長でありというわけでみなさま8月も終わりでございます夏休み
いかがだったでしょうか
何曲を卒業生からパパと一緒だし買ったんですけども夏休みの8月米地図をかで
なるべく動画を取るようにさせていただいたので結構のんびりのんびりもしれないな
結構時間をかけた動画をね何個か本当に何か面白いかどうかは別と
して僕がやりたい何ともっと動画を決行できたと思っております本当にいつも見て
下さった皆さんありがとうございます今回なんですけども僕は食うなんですねしょうば
内臓がそのサブチャンネル済車トっつって積んで出すんですけども
そのどっちでガチでやってる動画の中でもたまにねこう
上目ねーなって思ってるたまにあるんですよで僕はですねそのイン
ページとしてはサブチャンネルはもう一つだね雑の動画をあげたいですよ雑な道だと
ゲーム動画しか僕はあげたくないのですが割れた音手の込んだ動画をサブチャンネルで
出すっていうのはちょっとねあんまりしたくないと思ってるんでその行き場がない道だ
というのができるんです
まあ3つあげてもいいんだけどねあげてもいいんだけどもなんかこう
プライド的にちょっとこれは減ったくないなっていう動画マー
いわゆる ng 末 ng 動画とかね
実はこんなこともやってたよっていう動画が何個かありますので本当は公開する予定が
なかったどうぞ
良かったらみなさん是非ご覧ください母艦夏休み中にこんなことをしてました
ペア叩く見ていきましょうはいこれ
car
ん
par
car
ああああああ
me
ああ
goo
expense
me
で小突いている育成でやばいん
rar
ああああああ
も大丈夫です
タブ
ん
あっほっ
うーんさあこうだってくださ
思ってしまった果たしてこのノート1冊を単語で全ブレードにはだいたい
連続で続けるとどれくらいの時間がかかるのか今回はそれらを検証していきたいと
おもいます
あっ
バルーンは2つライブだと言い出していっ
それを乗り越えないとみたいだ際的だ
はいだからほんまに嘘じゃけどハワイ洒落や a
rar
みんな
ちょっと次にとってますか
ねえねえ
というわけで今日は
g
株式会社のダンテの家にしておりまー最適でくださってる人がいる g 州でござい
ます
8ば韓国もやってたんだぜ雪はあの動画のデータ消しちゃったんですけども実はですね
八角歳になる
元猿なんか心かーすぱさーじゅ丸稼ぐあって書くやつあれは中に本刷れてるの全部厚手
風呂に叩き込んで混ぜて一番勝つの各
すごいダイエットできるプロをつくってみたという動画があるんですけど動画でたは
ないです
なかったんですけど本当にやってただただ汗が出る動画で特に面白くなかったので ng
になりました学生のみなさん
学校始まりますけれどもまた今の時ゆるいで初めてつの道でも見てください
じゃんだ
cap
グーン
ああああああ
ブーム
っと
ん